why do you think that men get there why
do you think that they get better ties
because they let themselves because
women will competency test men
and
men will go through betatization through
a thousand concessions i you know i
talked about an interesting scenario in
my book which is a real life scenario
that i saw in a grocery store you know
myself whereas there's there's a guy and
he's in the uh baby eye with diapers and
baby food and
um he looks beaten down like his face
just like he just looks like a can of
smashed [ __ ] like he's had the worst
life ever and he's got a screaming kid
in the buggy another one in the basket
the wife's pregnant sort of thing and
she's yelling at him telling him what an
idiot he is because he put the wrong
diapers in the buggy
right and it's like
how do you get there it's like death by
a thousand paper cuts it's better
tization through a thousand concessions
and it and it starts with and by the way
it's the same guy that has a barbed wire
tattoo around his arm right like i'm
guessing you're close to the same age as
me so like that was a popular tattoo for
me you know back in the day when i was a
kid so he's that same guy like like he
was a badass guy that probably rode
motor motorcycles had a muscle car she
loved them the bits would give him all
the monkey sex hanging from the
chandeliers and blah blah sort of thing
and then you know 15 years later he's
this beta in a shopping cart you know in
the grocery store looking like he wants
to kill himself sort of thing so you
know it's just a sequence of of bad
choices and you know bad leadership on
the guy's part um i don't think that you
can blame women for it although women do
play a part in the in the equation
we do we test men i think that's what
when you talk about like the way the
superior man we will constantly test a
man and if he moves that goal post just
a little bit each time
that's where he'll eventually just be
just be given into whatever you want and
those tests disappear and start to go
away when she realizes that that that
there's no need to [ __ ] test you the
only reason why she's [ __ ] testing guys
is because it's a competency test she
wants to know that this guy can take
care of [ __ ] because a thousand years
ago if she didn't pair bond with a
competent guy it would spell certain
death for her and her kids at some point
so she had she had to make sure that she
was with a competent guy so that's why
they should test men but most guys fail
because they're told to be the nice guy
just do what she says
happy wife happy life that's like you
know the worst lyric that guys you know
regurgitate all the time she's my better
half you know come on guys
oh and so that's another thing that i
talk to my girls about in coaching
is that
you are not your man's whole world and
you shouldn't be like he should have his
own thing going on and you got to stay
busy
there's so many women who you know check
the phones and
get crazy when it comes to
wanting his attention all the time and
then when they get it obviously that's
clearly not what they want but right
i don't know how we
how we switch this in our
society because that that's where so
many problems run from is
the betatization and the testing and
everybody just
okay we're just going to cave
everything's going to be
whatever you say dark darling you know
yeah it turns into the segregation of
the sexes where women don't want to deal
with men right and men don't want to
deal with women
yeah okay that mgtow that you were
talking about right
i've never heard that before
so that stands for men going their own
way
yeah and there's a female acronym of wig
tau which is women going their own way
now too oh jesus
and
i mean like the interesting thing about
that is the vast majority of these guys
don't select this path in life like like
they're not choosing to go their own way
they're actually sent their own way
it's
you know it's like they're not
competitive in the sexual marketplace
and
they're invisible to women so they say
well i'm just going to take my toys and
march off over here and play in this
corner whereas women are just like we
don't care do whatever you want sort of
thing right because we're not we're not
even looking at you
um there's a very small part of the make
tech you know community where guys are
actually like just not dealing with
women even though they're attractive and
they're cop and all that sort of stuff
because they've been through enough
very rare for the most part it's guys
like being sent their own way
wow and
so they've completely given up on the
opposite sex
not really because
they're they're they're involuntarily
celibate where they would like to be
with women like the common trope is i'm
i'm funny i'm smart i have a pretty good
job
i don't understand why women don't like
me right
and it's like you know and then you look
at them and they're fat with a neck
beard and they play video games all the
time they're not influential they're
boring they don't have anything
interesting going on their lives of
course women don't want anything to do
with you i mean you know your your 40
000 a year job at walmart is not going
to cut it for most women today
right
and the dating apps make that imbalance
quite clear like there are so many men
on there and
just a little bit of women are the ones
who actually are getting the attention i
think or i mean that you're giving the
attention to those men right
yeah it's um
i think the swiping habits and i talked
about this in my books as well is that
women swipe right on
um sorry 80 of women swipe right on 20
of men right um which is why
the highest value men throughout history
have always generally dated or
maintained multiple women in their lives
right so whether you call it a harem or
whatever that may be depending on where
you live in the world um so there's
another old trope too where women are
women would rather share a high value
alpha than be straddled with a faithful
loser
wow do you feel like that's still true
today it is because multiple women will
be okay which was sharing a super high
value guy and they'll just look the
other way
there's a ton of different ways to break
that dynamic down and how it goes but
one of the great tragedies of
men's lives and women will never
appreciate this like one of the problems
that guys have is they want women to
love them in a way that they want to be
loved but they don't understand that
when the women only love them so long as
they're useful right like it's the whole
um
was it chris rock that said it in his
tambourine stand up only uh women
children and dogs are loved
unconditionally men are only loved under
the condition that they provide
something right um
so like one of the great great tragedies
there's a lot of good-looking high-value
men i mean you probably see them at like
the uh sean whelan you know type of
events tall guys tatted up lots of money
successful smoking their cigars they own
a bunch of guns you know blah blah blah
sort of thing and then they've got this
girlfriend sort of thing
and
they don't understand their
real true value and strength in the
sexual marketplace right and some of
these women they don't really appreciate
these guys like they're a little rough
on them they try to put them through
betatization but it's like if you're a
high value guy that's monogamous to a
chick that's generally of lower value
than you because women are hypergamers
they only date across and up
you'd think that they'd be a little more
appreciative right i mean but try to get
that message through to guys to help
them understand what their true value is
they don't want to hear it
hmm so women always marry up do men i
know we talk about all those a lot not
always like there are a few women that
will date or marry down where it's like
he's a stay-at-home dad and she goes to
work
but
she's not really happy like you can try
to you know convince people that you're
happy with that equation she'd rather be
at home with the kids you know doing
what women are better at doing and she'd
rather have him at work bringing home
the bacon but yeah generally speaking
more often than not women would prefer
to maid select men that are at either at
their level or higher like you've
probably heard with your girlfriends
like i just at least want a guy that's
at my level like i don't want to date
somebody that's broke i don't want
somebody with dad you know he doesn't
make enough money sort of thing he's hot
but he doesn't make enough money right
well she'll use him for short-term
dating because he's hot
but you know that's like the alpha seed
side of the
equation but then she's only going to
settle for a guy that's at her level
financially
um now with men did they how did
how did they normally go is they
normally go younger or
i don't know
you don't care you know like i have a
friend um you know there's an old joke
going around you have a friend like you
know when he comes over the fish stop
swimming you know because they're afraid
they're gonna get hit on sort of thing
men will go for just about anything but
generally speaking the things that men
prefer is youth and beauty
so
a 23 year old woman is it doesn't matter
how hot a 40 year old chick is she's she
just can't compete with a 23 year old
hottie not even close so youth and
beauty is what men prize and by the way
that's not just in western culture
that's throughout throughout the entire
world throughout history when surveyed i
think it was men between the ages of um
19 and 75
were asked what what demographic of
women are the most beautiful and they're
shown pictures in their culture of women
in that demographic they
universally select 22 to 23 year old
women
wow
wow so then why do you think that some
men go for the older women is that the
they have like lack of options low
hanging fruit mommy issues
it's it's it's usually lack of options
in low hanging fruit it's not often that
you'll find
a high value man that's successful
that's tall good looking you know has a
[ __ ] together that's like oh i want to
date a 70 year old whenever you see
those things show up on like those tv
shows you know the reality shows it's
always some 30 year old dork that lives
with his mom that starts dating a
seven-year-old woman that's basically
like a sugar mama that pays for his
video games right yeah they're not
having sex at all
hey guys i really hope that you enjoyed
that short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unplugged alpha dot com forward slash
shop when you click through you'll be
able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you